serge svetnoy and helena hutchins were
both ukrainians in america working
together on the film rust
he took this the last photo of her on
set
shortly after she would be fatally
wounded with a bullet fired by alec
baldwin svetnoy cradled the dying
hutchins for more than 20 minutes until
an ambulance arrived that senseless
tragedy could have and should have been
avoided he's now taking legal action
against baldwin and others for what he
says is severe emotional distress
was he expecting alec baldwin to pull
the trigger on the gun
not i'm not i
i'm not stated
nobody expected that at all that well
there will be an actual shot
this tragedy has been transported from
new mexico to beverly hills this is
where the announcement was made of a
pivotal moment in this case the first
lawsuit filed by any rust film crew
member it certainly won't be the last
svetnoy who now lives in la is being
represented by lawyers based here mr
svetnoy suffered tremendous emotional
distress
um
even though he was only hit with bullet
fragments
his dear friend
laid in his arms her blood on his hands
dying santa fe firing ems on the
location of emergency mr svetloy claims
he saw guns left in the sand unattended
in the days before the incident
alma hannah gutierrez reed was in charge
of firearms on set her lawyers claim she
was framed they say sabotage was the
reason for live ammunition in the gun
but svetnoy's lawyers say this is highly
unlikely they're saying that someone
committed a murder that they put a
bullet in a gun knowing it was going to
be fired at people that seems
specious that seems
suspect
the rust producers said in a statement
that safety on set was always their
first priority
but as sadness has made way to anger and
demands for accountability helena
hutchins final moments will now be
relived in court martha kellner sky news
los angeles